wo ist dein weg
vielen dank für die sachen ich gebe dir
bald zurück ja gerne nico die zwei t
shirts und die rose kannst du behalten
die tasche und die jacke brauche ich
unbedingt zurück auf jeden fall schon 10
uhr ich muss unbedingt was wir unseren
urlaub einkaufen lisa ist brauchen wir
eine sonnencreme saft wo kannst du ein
ich kaufe im supermarkt um die ecke dann
bringen doch bitte noch was an
immer ja ich habe ein geschenk für dich
ja für dich aber auch ein geschenk für
dich hier eine schutzburg für alle neuen
wörter auf deutsch danke immer wo ich
wohne bei frau kohlhaas sie ist sehr
nett und wohnt in der calwer straße
da ist der friedensplatz der arbeiten
max und tarek ich arbeite neben dem
theater und die felberstraße ist in der
nähe vom restaurant und der sprachschule
und hier ist die polizeistation hier
arbeitet oper